hi thanks for coming to our talk this
this is our talk on digital and social
resilience through the NYC mesh my name
is Jillian and my name is Michael we're
both volunteer organizers with nonprofit
called NYC mesh a noisy mesh is a
community owned wireless mesh network in
New York City we're offering low-cost
high speed and reliable internet to New
York City residents so this talk is
split into two different sections the
motivation will give a brief overview of
networking and the internet talk about
mesh networking in specific and the
inspiration for New York City mesh the
second half we'll talk on resilience of
the network how're decentralized
organization how we educate and train
the community and our goals to support
increased digital literacy so I'm not a
network engineer and we're going to make
a lot of simplifications but for the
purposes of this talk we'll get halfway
there and at least a common
understanding of what mesh networking is
and what we mean by all these terms so
the internet internet shell is a network
of networks connecting three and a half
billion people together this is achieved
through standardized protocols and in a
diversity of hardware these protocols
define how messages are sent across the
network and the hardware is what carries
a physical signal most networks use
copper cables fiber optic cables
antennas radio antennas or satellites
you can also build networks using thumb
drive stuck in your sneaker or cargo
planes full of hard drives or even
pigeons NYC mesh uses radio antennas for
the most part to carry this digital
signal this is a map of the undersea
cables that connects all the Continental
networks together to form the global
network and similarly on the continental
scale we have Continental networks to
join regional networks together regional
networks that join cities together at
that point between the city in your
house there's that last mile of how do
we connect your house to the global
backbone they
backbone and that is where the role of
ISPs comes in so a little bit about ISPs
ice piece came about or internet service
providers in the late 1980s when the
internet became open in public for
commercially in public use it was once a
highly competitive market when most of
the connections were through telephone
dial-up connections but as broadband
became the preferred access cable
companies already had lines to many
consumers so they became the dominant in
dominant industry the infrastructure was
then built with profit mostly in mind
and wealthier communities tend to enjoy
higher-end connectivity while poor
communities have slower speeds or none
at all and this this disparity is called
the digital divide I suppose also tend
to send favor a centralized model which
makes the architecture vulnerable to
attacks and outages in 2012 hurricane
sandy in New York City cut out Internet
when there was a lot of flooding and
even as we speak the Nord of northern
state of Kashmir has been without
internet for the last month when the
internet Indian government shut this
down this has impacted people's ability
to get medicine receive money and even
get their story out so in New York City
I think it's more appropriate to
describe the experience as compromised
connectivity well there are ways to get
connected in the city it's often a very
low quality low speeds and doesn't
really keep the people in mind however
also home broadband connections most
people only have an option of one or two
different providers and the prices are
high quality is low and service is
terrible there are some government
programs that offer subsidized internet
one in particular million people out of
the 8 million people are eligible for
this but it's very low speeds and it
doesn't really guarantee access in your
neighborhood so these problems aren't
really addressing they aren't really
solving the problem these solutions
here's a snapshot of a bit of NYC this
is Queens a bit of upper Manhattan and
the Bronx the red and pink areas if you
can see it
it shows the how there's a lot less
amount of connectivity if I were to move
over I didn't really want to rely on
Wi-Fi for this talk a lot of Manhattan
is white basically because there is low
connectivity while the outer boroughs
have the Bronx has at roughly 70% of
access to home broadband and another
interesting one is this is a map of
commercial connectivity or commercial
broadband access in New York City nearly
half of small businesses in the city are
unable to get a gigabit connection and
this really limits what kind of
businesses can exist in what
neighborhoods and it prevents current
businesses from being able to grow and
implement new technologies so the teal
as you can see is mostly in lower
Manhattan so like Midtown financial
district and it's a pretty stark cut off
once you get to Brooklyn Queens and the
Bronx
so NYC mesh we've outlined several
problems with IPS there are 10 severing
the digital divide or failing residents
the design at the last mile introduces
single points of failure for local
networks and residents have little
control over where and how the network
is deployed in Waseem has addresses many
of these technical and shortcomings of
traditional ISPs we have plenty of
bandwidth to share among the network we
operate on a donation basis and
subsidize costs for people that can't
afford the equipment to install on the
rooftops we operate with a mesh
topography which reduces the likelihood
of failure of any single node fails
we're also a community owns and
community maintains so the trust of your
internet connection extends beyond your
own home into the broader network that
you're connected to so what is a mesh
network a mesh network is a topology in
which the connections called nodes
dynamically connect to as many other
nodes as possible this dynamic routing
distributes the workload between nodes
and in the event that a few nodes should
fail the network is able to continue
exchanging information this self-healing
nature makes it impossible to shut down
a network from any single point and is
more resilient to either intentional
attacks or to natural
Aster's the idea of mesh networking has
been around for a long time even
starting the beginnings of the internet
in the 80s with ARPANET was a mesh
network but it's only recently in the
last 10 years or so that the technology
has been cheap enough fast enough and
user-friendly enough for true adoption
in a community on community broad
network mesh networks can be wired but
are often wireless because the the
installation costs are much lower in a
pure mesh network we like to see a true
tingled native connections the mesh New
York City mesh is a little bit off of
that model but we'll talk about that in
the next few slides so to diagram what a
mesh network is up on the upper hand
left corner we have a hub node Saratoga
hub which has a very fast connection to
the outer Internet and to the rest of
the mesh network in the lower right we
have a Jefferson hub connecting a lot of
individual nodes together if we add a
new node across the street from
Jefferson hub we can connect offer more
connections to each of the individual
nodes so that traffic has multiple
options of flowing back to the internet
or out to the rest of the mesh so there
are a lot of successful mesh networks
around the world and here are just a few
examples some include qui fee and Spain
Frei funk in Germany and even wasabi net
here in st. Louis
and we want to highlight griefing in
particular because they've been a large
inspiration and how we've established
NYC mesh goofy started in Catalonia
Spain in 2004 as a way to connect rural
farmers and its main concentration is in
Catalonia right now they have thirty
five thousand connections through a
combination of wireless and fiber and
they really are the gold standard of
mesh networks what's also really cool
about it is that all the networks are
managed on a hyperlocal scale that falls
under the umbrella of the gwee fee comm
foundation and this distributed model
can better respond to its community
needs also the fact that it's starting
catalonia is important to note because
this is an area that does have a long
history of grassroots and community
organizing
so as I said NYC mesh did establish
itself through queef II and we also use
their network Commons license
basically these four tenants promise
that users will have the freedom to
browse the network know how it functions
and they also agree to extend the
network so we've briefly covered what a
mesh network is how it differs from
conventional ISP networks and some
background of NYC mesh now we'll do a
deep dive into how networking topology
and the organizational structure of NYC
mesh makes it a resilient network and
community in the way that a single
antenna is not a network neither as a
single person form a community we aim to
build a robust network as well as a
robust community and we try to upend up
up and natural or long tread models of
leadership through a flat organizational
structure we do this through workshops
empowering individuals by forming
committees the result is a resilient
community that can build maintain and
organize the mesh network or
organizational structure mimics our
physical mesh network in a way and that
is designed to be decentralized
resilient and redundant we're
conservative with employing new tools
and software opting for those tools that
are most accessible to volunteers either
through price or through availability
and we take in a critical look at
finding hidden costs and volunteering
either in the time that you can give
physically where you're located or the
amount of money that you can spend and
traveling to and from the install sites
in short we are finding social solutions
to social problems all right so we are
also in building a network we're
building a community network I want to
tell the story of when I first started
working with NYC mesh I was super
excited as this alternative to the
Internet I don't need to use government
I don't need to use businesses this is
so cool we can do it ourselves
and so I went into my first install you
go to someone's apartment and you know
say hi and you're kind of like a in
service worker a little bit and I
thought that they were going to be
really excited about this too but really
the sentiment was that they just wanted
cheap
Internet so that's a bit disheartening
and we tried to stress no really in our
mission that NYC mesh is an active
project rather than a passive service to
be possibly consumed we also believe
that Canadian networks in the United
States shouldn't serve just those a
technical expertise but all people which
kind of has been a bottleneck that we
have been dealing with so while building
a diverse community we do understand
that now everyone has an extensive
background in network engineering or
even works in tech at all and instead we
need to build a community that reflects
the variety of backgrounds and interests
that especially make New York City such
a wonderful place so in response that we
work on work really hard to recruit
train and support volunteers by creating
opportunities that highlight their
personal strengths or interests right
now we have about 30 Corps volunteers
and about a hundred other who others who
come in and out throughout maybe the
year and our volunteers are organized
within one or more working groups and
they work to cover components that grow
and sustain our community and they
conclude training fundraising
infrastructure advocacy and we encourage
every member to take on leadership roles
pretty immediately and we'll give them a
community of knowledge and resources to
support them with their vision and so
we're really trying to break down the
barriers of entry to those building a
decentralized organization has been like
a really fun puzzle to work out because
you can't really rely on those habitual
processes of traditional organizations
so we have to ask questions we do have
to talk about volunteers and how do we
create a group of volunteers that
acknowledges invisible costs and the
privilege of being able to have time to
volunteer and how do you ensure that
group consensus is really effective and
not just listening to the loudest person
and reacting to that in building our
network organizing people is really the
hardest part and how are some ways that
we do it so one way we do it one thing
we do is we have organizational meetings
we used to just have happy hours once a
month and
the happy hours were definitely not
bringing in as many people who might
have wanted to join the network it's
inherently at a bar it was very
unstructured and it was a bit of an
intimidating place like even when I
first when I was a bit intimidated so we
have this org meeting that's a little
more open inclusive and we try to bring
some structure and giving them an idea
of like what NYC meshes and so our
breakdown is that we have people come at
the beginning do some updates what's
been happening in the network what's
been happening in the community have an
open call for people to talk about
projects they've been working on and
give a short presentation and then we
usually have a speaker from the local
community or someone who's working on
similar projects are organizing this
month is actually earlier this week and
we had a few people from the Queens
Public Library digital tech lab give a
presentation that was really cool to
really build partnerships and spread
their the word about them as well
and then we break out into working
groups and these working groups could be
outreach fundraise that fundraising
networking and we really try to get
people through the door from the
beginning and work in like working on a
project by the end of the meeting so
like this week we had I was working with
a group of newcomers who had never been
here before and probably talking to
about a group of 10 different people
about what we do answering questions and
we now have like a meet I need help on
the newsletter so I have a working group
next Monday and three or four of them
are coming to me and help with the
newsletter build out a calendar help
with design so it can be stuff that's
just organizational development as well
and so we're building a network
realizing that many people don't have
internet so we really need to make sure
that our materials exist in both digital
and analog formats one thing we give out
like every single event is this
volunteer pop quiz and it just said it's
like a fun way to get people engaged and
like towards the bottom it has like a
ton of different ways that people could
contribute to this organization even if
they don't think that they could
originally we also try to hold
educational classes outside of the
organizing so maybe one a month or so
and sometimes
our own like very mesh mesh specific
subjects such as networking 101 or
configuring antennas but we also tried
to work on different skills as well we
have a github class we have a grant
writing class and especially the grant
writing class and more neutral nonprofit
skills have been really effective on
engaging with the broader community of
people who might not have felt
comfortable coming to a tech event so
Julian just talked about building the
mesh community how do we build the
network itself we have a large group of
volunteers that sorry we have a large
group of volunteers that are installed
leaders and they've been on many
installs they know their way around the
hardware the configuration with each
install we also send out some novices
who have not been announced and install
before or don't really know their way
around after 2 or 3 installs we usually
are able to promote those install
offices into full install leaders I
might have actually read the next slide
before this so currently we have about
400 nodes in the New York City mesh
compared to 35,000 from greevey it's a
small number but we are the largest
active mesh network in North America we
have joined requests every day with an
average of join with an average of seven
new join your press everyday especially
after every season article in The Wall
Street Journal we have about 3,000 local
New Yorkers waiting for a new node in
2017 right after net neutrality is
repealed we had a huge spike in an
interest with the mesh we have been
averaging and install a week ever since
the publication The Wall Street Journal
earlier this year
our biggest bottleneck right now is
finding enough volunteers with
availability to meet the demands of
install requests so this is the install
leader training program that I spoke
about a few slides ago we also hold
works
so we trained a lot of people at once
the basics of the install process either
from creeping new cables to configuring
the routers just giving people the basic
skills that they need in order to
complete install successfully so the
structure of the network itself it is a
mesh network like we talked about before
we have three classes of nodes this
helps us navigate the unique urban
topology of the city where we have very
tall buildings lots of canyons we're not
able to form a true mesh network in
which every node is connected to many
other nodes we have more of a
hub-and-spoke model the hubs are either
composed of super nodes which have
direct access to the Internet backbone
their sector antennas that can cover
whole areas of the city
we have hub nodes which help connect a
lot of individual nodes together and
they provide free Wi-Fi to the
surrounding neighborhood and we have
individual nodes which consists of the
cheapest hardware that we can supply it
makes it more accessible to members but
it also has the drawback that the mesh
network terminates there it's not able
to continue on further this is a map of
lower Manhattan and Brooklyn showing our
physical mesh network the dark blue dots
are the hub nodes with access to the
Internet backbone the light blue dots
are our hub nodes and you can see the
majority of our nodes are those
individual nodes where the mesh network
terminates we're going through now and
trying to identify those buildings that
have line-of-sight to many other
buildings and upgrade those from
individual terminal nodes to hub nodes
to help make our network more of a true
mesh network this map is of the Greater
New York City area and it shows all the
great dots are the install requests and
they can't be connected to either
because they don't have line of sight to
an existing node well actually that's
the biggest reason what this also does
shows you see a lot of red dots that
weren't on the side before that aren't
connected and you see a hub node up in
the Bronx that's not connected to
anything down in Manhattan
these are nodes that are connected to
the the logical network they're
connected through a VPN so they can
still enjoy mesh services the applique
so we've written that only exists on the
mesh network even if they're not
physically connected to NYC mash either
there are VPN connections through their
home network or they're tunneling
through the link in YC program which is
another city partnership with a private
company to try to bridge that digital
divide this is a glimpse of some of the
hardware that we have on the left is
super node 1 and we have a sector
antenna up there 120 degree beam on the
right is a hub node where we have
omnidirectional antennas so 360 degree
coverage and down in the lower right is
that terminal endpoint point-to-point
antenna that we see on the individual
notes and a few more photos of our happy
volunteers some new members are members
generally are very hands on during the
install they have no training mostly
they're very curious about what we're
doing up there what does it mean to
connect to the network they're curious
about seeing the roof for the first time
as well as who are they connecting to
that's one of the biggest questions is
where am i connecting to who is that and
it helps engender this a sense of
community this sense of you belong to a
network both in the communal sense and a
technical sense so bridging a lot of
this together speaking of the digital
divide and how we build this network
together we cover a lot of classes of
buildings from 4 floor walk ups to whole
apartment buildings from commercial
property to NYCHA buildings so this is
Saratoga Village a nature building a
city-owned public housing building and
we have installed a hub node up on the
roof and we provide Wi-Fi access on
several floors of this building
connecting many residents we've already
passed through a terabyte of data this
year alone to this building we've also
connected in the same neighborhood a
Youth Center a community center we also
have a hub node on the st. Francis
School for the Deaf we're working with a
couple of management companies to wire
up new apartment buildings as they built
them in
all the gentrifying neighborhoods so
circling a bit back to breaking down
barriers of entry asking people to go on
to a small install can be a bit daunting
for many so we tried to do group
installations which still give people a
tangible understanding about how the
network is built and maybe funnel them
in sooner on this right-hand photo we
have a group of about 40 people on a
rooftop actually at the st. Francis
School for the Deaf and this is really
great because it gave people an idea of
like how to connect and how to catch or
like see the bandwidth and test it and
run an Ethernet cable down there's
actually the first event I attended and
I am here so that worked and then
sometimes finding a really large rooftop
can be difficult naturally so we do try
to do in presentations on our
installations and we hold this one here
on the left in early June and had about
70 attendees and roughly 20 or 30% of
the people who did attend that have been
involved in at least one project since
that in that time so it's been a really
effective way to get new volunteers and
get them actively engaged and so one
project we're really working on is a
neighborhood chapter pilot project and
it's to continue breaking down the
bottlenecks of leadership one thing that
I was seeing especially in the org
meetings is that I would get our
neighborhood or our mesh network is
mostly in lower Manhattan and Brooklyn
and people would come from Upper West
Side Bronx Queens all interested like
hey how do I get connected
unfortunately line-of-sight is a very
literal thing and we want to have a
physical mesh network we don't want to
totally do it through VPN and having you
know just one person coming from the
Upper West Side the next month a
different person is coming so there
wasn't really a way to really bring
people together so through these
neighborhood chapters we're hoping to
build momentum in neighborhoods and
hopefully get them to start building
their own network this is already
happening in Astoria where they had two
tech meetup and they just didn't want to
wait for us to make our way
two queens and so one area that we have
been pretty successful with the
neighborhood chapter is Greenpoint
Brooklyn um this man in the middle here
on his name is Thiago and he has agreed
to be the neighborhood leader of sorts
that has been what the hardest part is
finding people who are able to give up
sometime and really rally together their
neighborhoods but he hosts meetings
about once every six or eight weeks
people get together they strategize how
to install and it's a good way to meet
your neighbors really directly and then
on that far photo we can do those group
installations on a smaller scale so
about ten people can attend that rather
than 40 and that gives an even better
more intimate understanding of how the
network is built and so this is a
success we've had over the last summer
we're starting to actually you can see
some meshing happening there are some
triangles we have three hubs now and
definitely still a few endpoints it's
the most affordable option for many
people but it's starting we're starting
to expand and Greenpoint is at the very
top of Brooklyn so students will be able
to expand into Queens and another way
that we've taken with still neighborhood
projects and very neighborhood oriented
steps is in bed-stuy Brooklyn we went to
an area in on the east side we've been
speaking with them at community board
meetings and we went some block parties
here we went to a block party a few
weeks ago because that is every single
weekend in Brooklyn there was going to
be a different block party and teaching
people how to set up the antennas there
was a make-your-own ice cream station a
few feet away and we got more people
stopping at ours and there's been a lot
of success in bed-stuy it's really cool
we've built Oh quite a nice little mesh
network here and it's all attack being
sent through to Saratoga and we also
have to do general outreach as well we
do work really hard on that through the
classes as mentioned earlier
presentations to co-ops and community
boards in our local area local
partnerships such as with Queens public
library also Manhattan borough president
Gale Brewer is
huge advocate of us we are lucky to be
in New York City we have tons of
journalists tons of media so we do get
featured pretty regularly and we're also
working on doing like neighborhood house
parties as another relaxing less formal
way to get people psyched and interested
in this network realized that it's real
and they can have a portable accessible
internet and not have to deal with some
of the less savory parts of ISPs so our
outreach extends beyond New York City we
have a ton of documentation on the
website with a very active select group
we invite anyone who's interested in
building a mesh network to come join the
slacker bar to come visit us and join
one of our meetups we've had several
people from around the country come fly
out to New York City and ask us how we
do things or to see us in action
to join along on the install trainings
or to be part of the organics we've had
many people drop into our slack group
and ask us how do I get started were you
buying this equipment how do you
configure it we also go to conferences
like this strange loop battle mesh is a
conference that started in Europe a few
years ago that was originally designed
to test different mesh protocols against
each other literally a battle of mesh
protocols and in recent years has become
more community focused to again
reiterate this cycle of building a
technical network helps build a
community network next week Jillian and
another member from the mesh are going
up to Toronto for our networks to give a
workshop on building a physical mesh
using simple cheap routers we've learned
a lot over the past few years trying to
build a sustainable community
organization and trying to build out a
mesh network that survives that can
survive daily rigor some things that are
really working for us we are the
fastest-growing mesh network in North
America we are the only sustains
community network in North America
because of the hardware that we choose
and the the donations that we've gotten
we can survive on a small amount of
money and we've been able to scale up
volunteers that are very
pace some things that we haven't quite
figured out yet we're not sure how to
structure ourselves as a decentralized
organization there are a lot of
questions that we need to answer in
terms of funding in terms of outreach
and organization we've settled on some
really cool models but we're still
trying to figure that out we're not at a
scale yet where we can hire full-time
people to work on this project where we
can really expand our growth to meet the
demand and another thing that still is
very difficult is reaching consensus on
decisions so looking forward we do have
a few goals for the next year so we'd
love to be able to pay some employees
for their hard work it is estimated that
maybe once we hit a thousand knows we
might be able to pay someone in some
capacity for their employment and really
get that started we'd love to expand the
neighborhood group models because it
really helps promote local agency
they're able to run and support and
build their own network and not be
reliant on even a central organization
of NYC mesh we'd love to host more
applications on our network and really
enhance the physical community and so if
you want to build anything on our
network please I would love that to
people so people will actually be using
it and continue digital literacy
training and workshops that educate
consumers and citizens alike because
even if people are not able to get on
the network yet if they can go to some
of our classes or speak with us and like
have a better idea of how to select
their service with spectrum that's
helping us get the job done so and thank
you yeah that's everything
[Applause]
[Applause]
I think we can take a few questions we
are not a network engineer so just keep
that in mind
how does this typically work do we okay
you had your hand up really great
question I can actually yeah
so we used to be a pro well we have been
a project oh how does a decentralized
organization sign contracts and really
function as an organization essentially
so we used to be a project of the
Internet Society I sock and they were
our you know fallback for certain things
like that however signing contracts was
still relying on individuals to do that
and over this past year we've been going
through the process of applying for a
501 C 3 so that we can have NYC mesh be
its own nonprofit organization but in
doing that we're really trying to
minimize the amount of leadership and
centralization in that and that's been a
very tricky process to do we're really
trying to make it just for these like
major contracts and installations but
there's been a lot of back and forth
specifically with like establishing a
board has been a tricky situation
because there's a lot of notions with
that as most organizations are set up
yeah yes
do we have plans to reduce our reliance
on ISPs for connections of a longer
distance are ya sure
in short no there's going to always be
networks outside of our control and
especially talking about net neutrality
I don't think we'll see a day where
Facebook and Netflix are going to be
hosted on NYC mesh we're inherently a
very local network a very local
community beyond that we might partner
with other mesh networks in the far far
future to form a more regional mesh
network and perhaps reduce that reliance
but our mission now is very much local
and not beyond the bounds of New York
City however also connecting on the
backbone another issue is where internet
exchange providers are located and a
longer-term goal would be to create a
nonprofit internet exchange provider
which New York City doesn't have so
expanding the areas that we can connect
to the backbone at least on that sense
do a relationship with hub good question
um we tried to New York City is a very
very bureaucratic in city that has
already a lot of government contracts
already in place we're hoping that with
Saratoga which is kind of a dip into the
toes or dip into the water of that
organization we can now show them that
like hey we've been working with them
can we provide free internet but they
have currently like a deal with Sprint
and it was like you know it's just these
kind of messy public-private
partnerships that aren't really helping
people so yeah that guy in the back
sure so he asked about the cost for it
to hold no to install for the terminal
antennas that we showed the UB could do
you light beams where were you big booty
fanboys we like ubiquity a lot so we
have kind of a monoculture there but for
the light beams they run about a hundred
and ten dollars for the hub nodes
they're about a hundred and sixty I
think yes yeah the sector beams I'd have
to check with you on that but there's a
hundred to a few hundred dollars for all
the equipment the cabling the crimping
all this we also try to in our
installation price include a fifty
dollar volunteer fee as well that at
least helps mitigate some of the costs
that can be associated with leaving an
installation so that comes to the
account and it's also all donation based
we do try to find ways to subsidize
installations but we also hope that
people understand it is a community
network so if you can't afford the whole
200 or so dollars it's really helpful to
pay that to help other people I think I
saw your hand up
so we mostly rely on the application
level protocols to secure the network we
do have passwords for each of the
routers so it's a little bit less
trivial to hack into them but if you
have physical access you're able to
upload whatever firmware you want on the
routers which might allow some attack
vector where you're logging the traffic
but you would never be able to see the
contents of the messaging as long as
you're over HTTPS I think it was
recommended especially for the public
Wi-Fi we at least used to say be as
secure as if you were using a Wi-Fi at a
cafe or something so yes so have we
overcome organized opposition
such as
sure sure not too much we haven't had
too much fish back this kind of ties
into our education campaign of digital
literacy how do we get people to
understand what the Internet is how do
you connect to it I've heard a few times
where people especially in city-owned
housing where they'll say oh this is
just another tool for the police to use
we're in fact the police to her and it
has nothing to do with this mesh network
so in that sense yes it's a it's a
question of Education
we'll always fear the day where there is
PS will start to notice us and then try
to pass legislation but at this moment
no no organized opposition
yeah well we're working on that mostly I
think the neighborhood groups is really
one of oh sorry are we working what ways
are we working on maintaining the non
hierarchical organization I think that's
a big motive it's motivation behind the
neighborhood groups because we'd really
like to see them actually be building
their network sustaining it and even
funding it if possible similar to as I
said the goofy model earlier because it
is on their own separate organizations
that fund it but they have the support
of the Glee food foundation it's
definitely challenging but it's a work
in process it's at this point it's still
just like the questions that we have
weaved through our decision process yes
the question was what happens when the
laws turn against us and the FCC makes
what we're doing illegal I don't know I
want to see this answer on camera
[Applause]
yeah okay thank you so much for coming
to our talk we'll be outside in the
hallway to question